actually okay so let's go around the
table
if a dude wanted to sell you a dream
sell me the dream like what would you
want to hear from a guy and all of a
sudden like you got to go throw out your
panties because they're like soaking wet
you know was that a little inappropriate
it's fine no no tell me the dream that
the guy would have to tell you to for
you to be like all right I'm all in
Heather Lee
I agree that we want to be sold to dream
but I think actions speak louder than
words so my whole thing is if you wanted
to he would you can say that you want to
all you want but you gotta you gotta
prove it to me too you gotta back up
your words nothing he could say could
you know turn you on and of course you
can say it but I I like a man who's a
doer like don't don't say it just do it
talk is cheap that's great you just sold
me this now prove it yes is that fair to
say that's fair all right well Pearl is
looking to get soul to dream verbally
over here
I think she's right you can only sell a
girl a dream for so long okay before you
know she's like this guy might not have
a job
before we go down though like yes I need
let's start with the verbals what words
I'll even come back to you what words do
you want to hear from a guy to sell you
this dream not actions
um I mean I always look to see if he's
family oriented like wants a lot of kids
um if he's looking to do that soon
that's like what I would say
the dream so all a guy has to do is say
hey I'm trying to knock you up okay okay
okay no no sorry sorry you're right
you're right that's not it um hard
worker is something I look for
um I athletic you know I play basketball
I like going to the gym so athletic is
important so he needs to well that's
more of a physical thing right he can
look good yeah notice that but and the
hard work like verbally how does how can
he communicate that he's a hard worker
um you can just hear like the passion in
a guy's voice I mean I think like as
women we're kind of it's like natural to
us to kind of gauge how hard a guy works
um because you can just hear it if he's
like passionate about what he does
there's nothing more attractive than a
guy that's just really passionate about
what he's doing I think that's very
important that what Pearl just said is
you know there's like the famous phrase
Pursuit Excellence not women or chase
Excellence not women
what is it about a man pursuing
Excellence or working hard that has a
turn on and while he has his kind of
blinders on not focusing on chicks well
because you don't you know why that he
puts you on you on pedestal pedestal
like women don't like to be put on a
pedestal and like that the guy you're
his entire world so I just feel like as
women like we want a guy that's working
on something bigger than us
gotcha pursuing passion all right so I'm
going to come back to you before I go to
the two girls other than actions what
words are going to sell that dream to
well I was just I actually I do like
being put on a pedestal I was thinking
of that like I I want excuse me I mean I
want a guy who's going to put me first
and put the marriage and like the
relationship before everything else like
I want him to put you first before his
career
I mean it depends I think there just
needs to be a good balance between
everything I don't know what exactly
that balance is but I think it's
important to have a balance with
relationship career family but it's
always important to put your partner
spouse would you be okay with a
stay-at-home husband no
[Laughter]
by the way that's that's one of her
superpowers is being very inquisitive
and asking very good questions she asks
you a very good question do you like
simps because simps will put you on a
pedestal you're so beautiful I would do
anything for you you're the hottest girl
I've ever seen okay okay
and a man who
is choosing you and makes that yes
there's a difference between a simp and
a pimp but but answer her questions so
you don't want to sip but you also want
a man to put you on a pedestal I mean
yeah so maybe that was being a little
bit dramatic I just want a man you know
someone who
thinks very highly of me and you know
does the whole you know you're beautiful
you're great all that all that every
girls of affirmation
afterwards of affirmation girl yes words
of affirmation by the way Jamie you look
very lovely oh okay I'm trying to sell
you a dream right now girl that honestly
Works what what words do you want to
hear from a man that will be a major
turn on to you words words I think when
a man is describing like what he's
passionate about and like he has goals
and a vision like the vision is really
important and through those words he's
communicating how he's executing that
vision and how he's executed in the past
so I'm looking for like key Milestones
that show growth over like a course of
years and in his words if he's talking
about what he's done and how he's grown
and how he's like changed as a man to
become more of a man he's not a boy
anymore like that's what I wanted so
that's a turn on his growth vision
mission purpose because
if a girl was telling me I have this
vision and my purpose is I'm going to
create this company and I'm checking up
I'd be like yeah okay that's that's
doing nothing for me and I think that's
a the way a lot of guys feel it's like
that's great but I feel like the best
relationships the best are when like the
man has his purpose and his vision and
the woman locks into that and she's like
I'm gonna help you grow your business
your Empire like we had this
conversation the other day where it was
like happy wife happy life and like eyes
are rolling uh TLA is like okay I was
like give me something better than that
and the guy in the Super Chat said happy
King happy Kingdom I was like oh okay I
like that because of the king
he's the kingdom but he also has the
Queen the Queen's kind of doing her
thing
so I was reading some studies last night
actually that indicated that marriages
were more successful when the wife is
happy not that it's only the wife happy
like the man and the woman are happy but
when you focus on a happy woman her
mental health is good enough for her to
be able to take care of the home and
therefore teach the children like the
things that they needed teaching like
and Learn and Grow but women we don't
even know what makes us happy it's like
we feel different every single day so if
a guy's focusing on that it's like a
waste of his time because it depends
where we are in our cycle I mean you
already know you already know a couple
days before your period there ain't [ __ ]
anyway I would say are you happy I know
maybe women don't know what makes them
happy but I for a certain know what
makes me happy and what like I look for
and I've created a very peaceful life
for myself and being able to take that
into a relationship because I know what
I want what makes me happy then but I
think like we're not talking about you
specifically I was talking about women
in general
I mean just because women like change
their minds on things or or have
different conversations based on
different situations doesn't mean that
they don't know what makes them happy
I also think the ability to change your
mind and show that you're willing to
learn and grow with that person is a
good sign and a woman if she is willing
to actually listen to him and listen to
her man and then make decisions based
off of that and maybe change her mind
and maybe like oh I was wrong and take
accountability
sell me the dream if a guy needed to
sell you the dream oh man to become Mr
two girls one blunt be your man what
would you need to say to Mr wives over
here
by the way we're gonna we're doing a buy
one get one free gentlemen if you choose
two girls one blonde you get two yeah
Jamie and Emily all in one yeah they
just like pop up on the dates I'm like
hey guys how's it going I was bored
today double the cost but double the fun
also double the titties that's just how
math works yeah wow look at us you can't
read today but at least you can do math
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible